have heard about green beer but have you
heard about wines that drink green well
here today is diana breyer valley cheese
and wine owner and the wonder woman of
cheese hey to talk us through
green drinking wines now i've never
heard this doesn't mean the wines are
green right no no no so this is kind of
an interesting concept that i've been
learning about as i've been learning
about wine which is very recent for me
everybody knows i am the wonder woman of
cheese but i'm also getting my sommelier
certifications as we speak so as i'm
starting to study these wines i'm
noticing really interesting flavor
profiles coming out of them that remind
my palette of things that are green so
if we talk about maybe in a champagne
have you ever tasted that beautiful
green apple note or if you've ever drank
a sauvignon blanc from new zealand you
might smell a little bell pepper or some
lime so those are going to like read to
your palette as things that are green so
they they they are not green but
they trick your mind into thinking they
taste green yeah have you ever had like
a really plushy red wine and you're like
oh this just tastes like red fruit yes
this is gonna taste great so what do we
have here we're starting off with a
sparkling tarantis this is from
argentina and the toronto's varietal is
known for being extremely aromatic okay
but in this dolce sparkling form you
have a lot of notes of like key lime pie
and baked green apple and a little bit
of herbaceousness you might even catch a
little cucumber in there i certainly do
give it a whirl it's beautiful
one of my favorites for sure
it just has this beautiful effervescence
some tropical fruit notes come forward
this is excellent i am not the biggest
white wine this is probably one of the
what is this again so this is this
little sparkling
uh how much does this retail for so this
one retails around 21.99 for me i yeah
so i will save you five cases
oh my gosh okay i'm don't throw this
away don't throw that away i'll rebuild
you let's make a cocktail tell us a
little bit about this to taste some more
green wine also can be in different sort
of applications so just as much as we
have the sparkling dolce torontos here
we also have jardesco which is an
apertivo so this is actually a
family-owned
wine producer an aperitif producer in
california it's a father and son project
and this is actually
like totally herbaceous lots of pink
peppercorns in here but it's actually a
very high alcohol content at 17 so we
use this to make wine cocktails oh it
actually acts as a very much like an
herbaceous but blank canvas upon which
you can paint whatever picture you want
so i chose lime zest and rosemary and a
little bit of ginger beer and you're
going to have this beautiful sort of
summer cocktail it's great for poolside
it's great for
any where you want to be and it actually
does have a hint of green too it is yeah
it has a little tinge of green to it you
can actually notice in the bottle there
is a little bit of green because they do
use herbs when they're making herbs that
you put in there it's just so okay so
really
oh that's just delicious so this should
be like just a gentle herbaceous moscow
mule-esque situation that's what i was
going to say it's just like citrusy but
light and oh that is delicious you taste
the rosemary you taste the lime and
that's another thing that's going to
drink green on your palate and you
always pair up your wines with delicious
cheese what did you bring for us today
we have a minute left let's show it some
of these delicious cheeses okay so we
have over here this is a pistachio torta
actually i am the third owner of valley
cheese and wine and the original owners
came up with this recipe and the third
and even through every ownership we
still make these today oh my gosh so
this is a fresh goat's milk cheese that
we add honey to and then we top with
fresh ground pistachios so this is going
to be your pairing for the sparkling
dolce torontos because that nuttiness is
going to play beautifully with the key
lime pie notes you're going to have that
sweetness from the honey and that
tartness from the chev you can pick that
up and bite right out of it
try it
you're going to love it
this is such a fun one and we have a lot
of people that come into the shop and
just absolutely love this it's beautiful
for springtime it's easy to pair with
bubblies roses sauvignon blancs this is
absolutely decadent don't mind if i do
um
i'm gonna help myself do a little bit
more of this
where can people find you there so okay
so i am valley cheese and wine i am in
henderson i'm on horizon ridge parkway
in between vale verde and stephanie um
we are always here for your cheesy and
wine needs if you need to come in and
talk about more wines that drink green
we even have red wines like carmineer
from chile that have beautiful
eucalyptus notes in them she's the best
come on over and hang out with me it's a
lot of fun we'll be right